So now it's time to learn about how to query for
conferences. But for our queries to be useful we actually need
to have some conferences to query over. So go ahead and
create a couple conferences, maybe more if you like. You can
use the create conference page in your app to do that
or you can use the API's explorer, whichever you like. The
Create Conference page is a little nicer because it limits the
choices of the topics to valid topics and it uses this
nice date picker for selecting the start date and the
end date. So the only property that's really required is
the name. All the other properties will default to the
default values. But for our queries to be useful, you're going to
need to set a couple of these properties. So go
ahead and create a conference. So you have to be sure
to specify the conference name. Can choose a city. You
are going to need some conferences in London. Going to skip
the description, and you are going to
need some conferences in London that are not
about medical innovation so let's make this one,
this would be Health and Nutrition right? Because
it's about chocolate. I'll pick a start date
in June. End date, probably should be after
the start date. And then we'll create the
conference. So go ahead and create some conferences.
You're going to need a conference where the city is
London, and the topic doesn't include medical innovations. Create another
one where the city is London. The topic includes medical
innovations. And the start date is in June. And the max
attendees is greater than ten. And you feel free to
create some other ones as well. If you didn't get
all that, don't worry. When you need these particular conferences,
I will remind you to create them, if you didn't already.
And again, we already talked about this, but you're
going to need to use the datastore viewer in the
Admin Console to review your entities. To make sure your
conferences actually got created and saved. Now that we've got
some conferences, it's time to write the Query Conferences function.
We've already learned that using Objectify to get an entity
by key, you use the load method. So here's the
code to load the entity if we know its key.
Call the load method on ofy, call the key method passing
the key and then now so it happens right away. This works
if you know the key of the entity that you want to
get, but for conferences, we don't know what the key is, because
we let app engine create the key for us with an
auto allocated ID. So we actually don't know what the keys are
for the conferences, but actually it turns out that doesn't matter. We're
just going to query for them. So here's how you create a query
to get all entities of a given kind, ofy().load(),
as we did before, but this time we specify type.
And then in our case since what we want
to do is get all entities of a given kind,
we need to pass Kind.class to type, so here's
the query to get all entities of a kind recipe,
so you see we just specify Recipe.class here. You
can also sort the results based on a property value.
So here's how you'd sort the recipe entities according
to their name. You just call the order method
and you specify the property to sort on, and
we're going to sort on the name. So try to go
ahead and execute the query, you call the list
method. So here's what you'll do to add the
functionality to query for all conferences. In the conference
API class, you're going to add a method called queryConferences.
There we are, queryConferences. You're going to have to write
this one for yourself. See here I define the @ApiMethod
to expose the function as an end point and to
specify the name, the path, and the httpMethod. In this case
this needs to be POST. And for now it takes
no arguments. See that? No arguments. You're going to fix that later
on, but for now it takes no arguments. You're going to
add the code to query for all conferences sorted by name.
And then you're going to return the query list.
So see here we have the error for
query, so you're going to need to fix that. And you actually need to import the
objectify query and that's in com.googlecode.objectify.cmd.Wuery.
So make sure that you import the query that goes with objectify, not
the one for the native data store. So after you've read your query conferences
method, you can try it out in the API's
explorer. You go to the API's explorer on localhost
and you see the services, you're probably going to need
to refresh the page here, otherwise you won't see the
queryConferences method, but here now, here we have queryConferences.
You click on it. Now, if you recall we
didn't provide any input arguments, so there's no request
body to fill in, so just press Execute and let's
see if we've got any conferences. Yes. I only
have one conference called App Engine for All, and here
we see it in the response. You can also
use a Show Conferences page in the UI, because this
page also sends a call to queryConferences. So this
is an example of what you might see in the
Show Conferences page. Got a list of all the
conferences that have been created. There's no point adding filters
because the current implementation of
queryConferences doesn't know anything about filters.